what's going on guys this is Rob and I
just woke up so you're gonna have to
bear with me here but we're covering
both of the Batman tie-ins for the night
terrors event and like most of everybody
on Earth at the moment including most of
the Superheroes Batman is contending
with what is in effect his own worst
nightmares right that's the power of
insomnia this new God of nightmares he
can trap people inside their own heads
and so what this does is Bruce initially
wakes up within Crime Alley and this is
just kind of a significant moment in his
life most all of you guys know the
origin of Bruce Wayne right there like
his mom and dad were shot and killed and
then he inherited their money and then
eventually became Batman Crime Alley is
where they died and so in a lot of ways
he just kind of relives these
exceedingly traumatic moments in his own
life now some of that is due to him
really kind of needing to remember why
he does all this in the first place but
some of it is also just a form of
self-torture right just putting himself
through these terrible situations over
and over and over again and never really
being able to move past any of the
original trauma that made him into the
person that he was and so while some of
this is real and tangible and it's kind
of a psychological effect other aspects
of this is just his own brain screwing
with him so for example like his mom's
pearls just come rolling down towards
him and almost destroy him and he ends
up jumping inside the Monarch Theater
now one of the things to remember is
that insomnia is not manipulating or
controlling any of this this is 100 his
own mind doing this and so that's why
when he gets into the Monarch Theater a
kind of projector just fires up and
shows him what's actually going on in
the real world right now which is that
Boston bran dead man is currently in
possession of Batman's body as dead man
tries to basically find a way to wake up
all the superheroes who have fallen
asleep and really most of the world's
population but within his own mind and
even once Batman realizes this he's
yanked to another location which is
actually his parents home right like the
old Wayne Manor and as he's there and
instead of just simply seeing the
gravestones of his parents he's forced
to witness the gravestones of everybody
that he loves and cares about right
that's kind of symbolic idea that his
actions will inevitably lead to the
death of everybody he loves and more so
than that the gravestones seemingly
stretch on to infinity and so it puts
off this philosophy right this idea that
Batman is nothing more than death and
destruction reincarnate and that's it
now one thing to know right this is an
important thing to understand here when
it comes to Batman's Mythos that was
kind of the case but not the case it
didn't really become the case until the
death of Jason Todd right the old Bob
Kane Bill Finger Batman stories from
when he was first introduced in
Detective Comics Batman number one yes
they were really really dark but it was
just kind of him doing whatever he
needed to do to solve a crime and his no
killing rule hadn't really been
established by that point he got really
goofy in the 1960s he got serious again
in the 1970s under Neil Adams and Dennis
O'Neil but then Jason Todd dies and the
death of Jason Todd was one of the first
real times in DC Comics where they
introduced this concept of just like
collateral damage that Bruce Wayne being
Batman will get people killed and it'll
be the people that he cares about and
loves the most and ever since then ever
since the death of Jason Todd in death
in the family it's been this concept of
Batman and this kind of ongoing fear
could what happened to Jason Todd happen
to Tim Drake Duke Thomas could it happen
to Dick Grayson right Catwoman any
number of people and so this fear is
something he contends with on a regular
basis and even when insomnia does
manifest in this kind of mock get up
that makes him look like Robin although
he's got an i instead of an R he still
toys with this very concept now one of
the things to know is that his attempt
to manipulate Batman is one half
half-hearted and the other half is just
a really really poor attempt right it's
like I grew up in Gotham and I lived
here my whole traumatic life it was
always so cool that we not only they
have our very own superhero we had the
Batman in fact I'd love to be your
sidekick all you have to do is help me
find the nightmare Stone like he's
actually trying to get Batman to help
him do this and the reason why is we
talked about in our previous video is
that Dr Destiny a guy who previously had
the dreamstone had warped it twisted it
turned it into the nightmare Stone and
then hid it in the nightmares of
somebody on Earth it's quite literally a
needle in a haystack and so this kind of
half-hearted attempt to try to get
Batman to his side of course it doesn't
work and because it doesn't work you
basically end up seeing these sort of
physical manifestations of the people
that Batman cares about just literally
digging themselves out of graves right
like Commissioner Gordon and Batgirl and
so on and so forth and even Selena Kyle
Catwoman shows up here as a sort of
Twisted and dead caricature to a degree
and so one of the things that he does is
he sort of taunts and toys with Bruce
Wayne Right with Batman and saying like
your greatest fear is happy penis that's
your absolute most terrifying fear is
that you could become a happy person
because all you've known is struggle and
strife now that is to a degree a
relatively accurate statement right
there's a really good book out there
called how the mind works and it talks
about this and it talks about like
trauma responses right that people will
respond to trauma in a variety of
different ways some people will develop
disassociative identity disorder right
so varying personality is designed to
cope with the trauma that they can't
cope with with their quote-unquote core
personality other people wall themselves
off from the world in the case of Bruce
Wayne he doesn't really have did but
what he has done is just built up these
walls it's kind of a safety measure to a
degree right if I never let people in I
never have to experience that kind of
trauma again and then to take it a step
further and to justify his own
perception it's I'm gonna go into the
world and I'm going to make sure that
nobody has to experience that again and
it creates this really interesting
situation where he is both a character
suffering from a horribly traumatic
experience doing what most people with
trauma responses do and approaching this
in the worst way he possibly can but at
the same time finding some measure of
benefit in doing what he's doing and one
of the things that he does is he says
like I'm not afraid of being happy but
his actions would actually say otherwise
right in a moment when he had a chance
to marry Catwoman for example ultimately
she rejected him but he never chased her
he never went after there and said no
we're absolutely getting married because
you're in love and I'm loved we'll do
our thing and we'll run off together and
the City of Gotham will take care of
itself and that'll be it and so the
other part of this again because it's
kind of his mind messing with him is
that he actually just kind of like
coughs up this gigantic bat with a gun
attached to it which is really really
twisted but is incredibly symbolic
because what this does is it represents
two sides of the same coin it represents
what Batman has become but also what he
could have been because remember Batman
has a no killing rule right specifically
he never uses guns under any
circumstance not even to taunt or wound
people because guns are what cost him
his family and so in a lot of ways this
bat represents that manifestation yes
it's Batman but like Batman with a gun
or something along those lines which is
kind of ironic because this is headcanon
so I'm not going to swear to the fact
that it's true but I want to say that in
some of the very early comics in DC that
Batman did have a gun but again I'm not
100 sure about that so I'm not gonna
swear and honestly it's not really
important enough to look up but it's
just one of those things where in
response to this because of the fact
that insomnia tells Batman I'm not the
one doing this your mind is the one
doing this you're the one doing all of
this it's the worst possible thing he
could have said and the reason why is
because yes Batman is a prodigious
fighter and he is arguably the best
fighter in the entirety of DC Comics
depending on who you're talking about
right he's gone against Superman he's
faced off against Bronze Tiger he's
fighting all kinds of different people
but the deadliest weapon in Batman's
disposal is his mind and so to turn
around and tell him your mind is the one
doing all of this is to tell him you can
control everything that's going on right
now you can decide what you do or do not
do and so that literally drives Batman
to a point where he just tells insomnia
thank you then like thank you for giving
me that piece of information transforms
himself into a sort of God of nightmares
and then literally just takes off right
just effectively bails and gets out of
there as fast as he possibly can the
problem with this is the mind is a
powerful thing and so even despite this
sort of Newfound power that he has
within his own mind his mind is still in
control what he has to do is figure out
a way to take it over and this all comes
to bear when he's suddenly transported
yet again wakes up in Crime Alley and
he's Joe Chill he's the guy that kills
his parents now again this is more of
like a philosophical thing right this is
not the real world so it's not like he's
been and sent through time right and
he's the guy that like solidifies his
own existence it is a nightmare for him
right these are all nightmares that he's
experiencing right what if something
happened where he ended up being the one
to kill his own parents and so the kind
of child version of himself right that
was sort of witnessing all this begins
to freak out and begins to like attack
him ripping off the kind of Joe Chill
skin so to speak revealing the Batman
underneath and it's like you wanted to
be Batman right admit it right our
parents dying and all that kind of stuff
it was the Catalyst because you just
wanted to become this person and just
really sort of tearing through and
almost getting to the heart of what
Batman is almost coming to this
conclusion that like it was never about
the death of his parents right it was a
catalyst but he always had a kind of
inner Darkness inside of him that he was
always twisted and screwed up ever since
he was a little kid for any number of
reasons and he was always destined to
become Batman it's not necessarily true
but who said that nightmares are
rational in the first place and so the
thing about this is that as these
different kind of personalities begin to
like multiply and duplicate and so on
and so forth Batman just gets out of
there as fast as they possibly can but
he starts to realize what he can do
within this realm for example he can fly
and he even makes a comment he says in
the real world I may not wish to have
Superman's powers But Here in My Dreams
it takes on a different meaning right so
him being able to just kind of fly away
and Escape it really represents more of
him being able to harness control over
himself than anything else now he says
my mind catalogs its dreams right some
are a glimpse into my complicated heart
some are lies now what's so ironic about
this and interesting is that it does
show a Dark Knight Returns moment when
Batman fights Superman and Batman
overpower Superman the real question to
ask here is does Batman dream of this
and if he does why does he dream of
alternate realities is that the way
dreams work in DC Comics are they
borrowing a page out of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Doctor Strange 2
when they said your dream games are just
glimpses into another person's life or
another variant of you in the Multiverse
and like that's it but what he ends up
doing is he he comes to the realization
the only way for him to really seize
control of his own body right to really
get back to the real world is to focus
on something called the black door and
behind it is his absolute worst
nightmare the nightmare the fear
whatever you want to call it that he
keeps locked up chained away so no one
can access it not even him and so even
when insomnia does manifest he says like
is this where Dr Destiny housed my
nightmare Stone and he tells Batman open
it up right open the door now the real
question you got to ask yourself here is
do you really want to open a door to
Batman's worst nightmare like the guy is
the living embodiment of just fear right
like his job is to scare the absolute
tarnation Eddie do you really want to
see what this guy's worst nightmare is I
mean that's that's I'm just throwing it
out there right I'm just kind of saying
there are some things better left to
unsaid and there are some things you
just don't ask for and that's it
now what's so funny about this and and I
really feel like this is DC just kind of
playing it fast and loose and even just
kind of having a little bit of fun with
the Batman comic right is that
something's going on out there in the
real world which is actually covered in
the main night terror story itself we
will cover it but the control that
insomnia has is beginning to loosen now
this is also because Batman's starting
to take his mind back so he's starting
to come out of this nightmare and he's
starting to push insomnia out but one of
the things that happens is that he
literally like fires off shots at Batman
and he just kind of like stops them like
Neo from The Matrix in literally the
exact same way like the little circles
right bullet time the bullet's slowing
down it's it's cool it's it's just it's
fun and he really can't be too upset
about it but ultimately insomnia is
essentially forced out right this guy
ends up just leaving and disappearing
entirely Batman destroys the gun bat
right and then in turn faces his own
fear here right face is the thing that
terrifies him the most now this is
probably one of the greatest Batman
moments that I think I've ever read
about because what he does is when he
gets in there he says this is not part
of my nightmare this is me he says
insomnia was right about one thing
before there is a piece of me forever in
that alley the sound of gunshot is
nothing unusual in Gotham so when my
parents died it didn't draw any
attention I was alone with my parents
bodies for 90 minutes before A Beat cop
happened to pass by but none of that is
the nightmare I hid behind the black
door this boy was alone in that alley
and he made a promise to himself a vow
of Vengeance to make sure that whatever
happened to him never happened to anyone
else and ever since that day I have
wondered if this boy in the alley saw me
today would he be scared or disappointed
in what I have become and that's
Batman's biggest fear and it's actually
beautiful to be honest with you guys and
it really humanizes him in a lot of ways
the reason why I say that is because
when you read Batman comics especially
in the modern era now more so than
really in years past there really seems
to be very much about Batman that is
very much inhuman he doesn't really feel
like a human person he feels like a
person that just maybe he has like
unbreakable skin or maybe he has like a
mind that works like a computer right
but he's got to have some kind of power
like some kind of an ability right it's
hard to see him as an actual person one
because he Associates with superheroes
so much and two his Comics even in the
modern era just in a lot of ways feel so
over the top that like no human being
could actually pull that off that's one
of the beautiful things about Dennis
O'Neill and Neil Adams run in the 70s is
that it was very much a return to Batman
feeling more like a James Bond type
character that was fallible and could be
beaten as opposed to a guy who could
come out on top no matter the
circumstance and so this whole idea of
his biggest fear being that he let
himself self down that he disappointed
that kid that he strayed so far from the
path that maybe there's no conceivable
way for him to come back is the most
conceivable fear that you or I or
anybody could possibly relate to right
because it really is kind of like how us
as people function I would go so far as
to argue this little kid representing
Bruce Wayne it really is the idea that
he's disappointed himself right that he
is not he he knows he's not what he's
supposed to be he knows he's not doing
what he's supposed to do but then you
get this amazing moment between the two
of them and so they finally have this
conversation where he finally confronts
this fear he says that for a long time
you will live in the shadows isolated
hidden and shielded away from anything
but your own mission but others will
find you in the dark friends that you
can't imagine some who can fly and shoot
lasers from their eyes some who can stop
bullets with their bracelets and who are
so fast they can break the speed barrier
and children who will make you into a
better man and where this little little
kid is like that sounds like a dream
right sitting here surrounded by his
dead parents feeling nothing but pain
and anger and sadness when he says that
sounds like a dream it's a beautiful
thing and Batman says it's more than
that it's your family I'm doing
everything I can not to make a fast and
the furious joke but it's one of those
things where he literally hugged the
younger version of himself and says
thank you right and his younger version
says I'm proud of you but why are you
dressed like a bat and he says because
they can be scary and this and his
younger self says bats are cool and so
it's him accepting that yes he would be
proud like he would be proud of the
person that he'd become he would be
proud of who he is it's a beautiful and
wonderful thing so in turn he tells his
own mind wake up and he just breaks free
of Boston Bran's control snaps out and
just starts controlling everything of
his own accord he jumps back to his own
body Batman is back now the issue here
is in Arkham Asylum the nightmare realm
seems to have taken complete and total
control be because it looks like the
nightmare realm out in the real world
and so Batman is not entirely sure if
what he's seeing is real or false enter
his son Damien Wayne who says this is
the real world and we lost with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end if you guys want to get caught
up on night terrors make sure you click
this playlist and I will catch you all
later
peace